herzlich willkommen zur heutigen video
leute ich möchte auch den schleim machen
und riesenschlange auch ein waffeleisen
tun weil er wird schon fleißig mit
rennwagen sitzen trend und
wahrscheinlich gemerkt welchen genervt
weil ich bin nach dem losgelaufen habe
alles eingekauft mit diesen kleinen
betreut ist ultra teuer was man da
überhaupt pappe zeug gekauft hat es
ausprobiert
ihr seht hier mischen schritt fügen wir
hinter in diesen kleinen rheinischen
motiven glitzer gekauft wird wird das
schön verrührt als nächstes kommt in den
kleinen die farben rhein und in roten
und blauen das macht ihn aber was daraus
geworden
überhaupt nicht funktioniert klappt auf
jeden fall schon klima hatte das fest
bald schon was mit glitzer aufgebraucht
dieser überteuerte klima wird auch leer
das macht man dann allerdings nicht mehr
zieht los um sich anderen klima in black
3 stück davon und einen fertigen schleim
damit wird einfach austesten können so
ja da kommst du bitte wieder dazu und
hier ist die schiffe wieder in die
falsche richtung auch nach belieben
video heute auch noch eine waffel album
gekauft wollte eigentlich im video
150 euro angegeben so eine kraft gipfel
eigentlich klingt also den völkern
lieben
hier sind die regale von drei flaschen
kleber aber eine ganz andere kompetenz
der in tief als erwacht sein leben und
er wird ein gefährt so gemacht
rote farbe rein und ihr fehlt davon
berührt ziemlich wohl letzten jahr schon
wieder bei der kritischen phase
angelangt und zwar bei dir wohl rein
kommen wir jetzt ein bisschen macht
pulver und rühren dass ein haben schon
werden
dort funktioniert glaube ich wir tun
jetzt ein bisschen rasierschaum rhein
bei manchen machen dürfen ich glaube ich
hab mal richtig perkovic so wirkt die
konsistenz zum kneten weil es mir so
eine
leute leute habt jetzt nicht endlich mal
aufhören zu kleben an den händen als
irgendwie ist schlau machen leute nicht
zu 100 prozent mein ding weil diese
nicht ganz sicher was falsch hilfe beim
schreiben wird köln bleiben was soll ich
zu noch mehr bitte man vom rest ist wenn
das nicht funktioniert leute dann neben
bakterien aber ich muss irgendwann noch
mal ein video machen wo ich den
richtigen schleim hinkriege also
hinkriege hinkriege
die lassen wir jetzt mal ganz kurz
stehen ich mache meinen händen
und dann will ich sein stieg dann machen
wir erstmal den gekauften schleimen
drauf danach den selbstgemachten alte
machtelite einheitsliste triffst du
richtig nachdem billiger neuer technik
und der schleim ist immer noch kein
schleim gepflegten händen und irgendwas
bald eigentlich fühlt man dann mehr
waschmittel dazu wenn wir mehr beispiele
dazu machen wir deutlich flüssiger ich
habe keine ahnung was einst vorgehabt
wieder frei mich packte jetzt mal aus
und zwar bitte einfach damit ich nicht
in den inflationsfalle welches wie
gefällt euch die kommentar- und
auszubauen weitere 50 euro aufnehmen und
nicht zum ziel ist diese wunderbare
schreien so laut wie erfährt der fertige
schleim und der funktioniert einfach zu
dass er soll unsere herrscht eine fusion
nach oben direkt über uns ist ein
rauchmelder ich hoffe mir das jetzt echt
keine rauchentwicklung gibt aber wir
legen das ding einfach mal drauf
okay wir machen wir einfach mal die
deckel drauf
in der zeit des abwartens diese filme
hier ist auch dass ein zug auch einfach
mal kurz hoch läuft doch sehr geliebt
und nicht einfach komplett schon
aufgelöst ist weil das irgendwie auf
wasserbasis oder so ist aber es fängt an
zu rauchen
ich hole zwar den schleim hier raus
jetzt noch genau dass ich wieder zurück
auf dem tisch hiermit das richtige sind
uns zu details macht zurück in der er
kurz sogar noch wir lassen die ihnen
jetzt mal ein bisschen abkühlen in der
zwischenzeit diese glitzer perlen in
unseren reihen
vielleicht halten die wenigsten den
ganzen bus zusammen ein wenig vom
reiterverein nach wenn ihr bereit seid
sie lachten leichter und wir lachen wir
uns kurz backen dann kommt er raus ist
der perfekte schleim ab deckel drauf ich
probieren derzeit ist natürlich heiß
hier raus
befragt nach wickie das ist oft alles
über das heißt wir machen weiter der
decke rät sich auch ein bis zwei kocht
einfach wir machen wir noch mehr drauf
streichen
genau das ist nämlich mein ziel gewesen
leute das hier ist echter schleim glaube
ist einfach die bestehenden zucker kern
richtig gebt ihnen lasst das mal ja
leute abonniert auch mal wieder
schlagwort ist immer ob ultra heißt aber
wer kommt noch also wenn ihr darum dafür
ist die moral vom heutigen video macht
kein schwein gekauft ihn einfach auch
wenn er voll überteuert ist und guckt
sie wollen wir probieren es gebrodelt
man sieht schon sehr nach krebs aus
darum nächsten like das mädchen stück
davon also alles noch ein bisschen
kochen lassen
ich rufe nicht klappt schon deutsche was
haltet ihr von der idee
ich will jetzt einfach diesen schleim in
den anderen schreien